[Music]
thank you
hi guys it's Quinn here if you enjoy my
videos consider hitting the like button
it's the only way the YouTube algorithm
really notices me if you'd like to do
more to keep this channel afloat
consider donating through the PayPal
Link in the description or checking out
our patreon thanks guys so much
in the Dune Universe the power of the
patershot emperor sharam IV rests on his
wealth his influence in the landsrad and
his sardicar army
the emperor is one of the most powerful
individuals in the known universe his
wealth comes from the fact that his
house the house of Carino holds a
majority of shares in shown company also
known as the combine hanette Ober
advance or mercantiles Joan company
facilitates all Interstellar cells in
the Galaxy this essentially meant that
choam controlled the sale of spice and
the emperor got a hefty portion of each
sale spice was the most valuable
substance in the verse the lens rat of
course was made up of the great houses
of the Imperium this included house
Atreides house harkonen and others the
emperor was at the head of the landsrad
he had the sole power to Grant and
remove fiefdoms of planets throughout
the Imperium early in the book Dune
house Atreides is given the theft over
the world arrakis at the command of the
emperor
themselves were known to be some of the
most brutal Warriors in the Galaxy their
strength came from the harsh realities
of the planet in which they were trained
a prison World known as seleus secundus
the world had a degree of hostility
comparable to the world of Iraqis
all of these elements contributed to the
emperor's power his wealth his military
his fluence
but what are the emperor's weaknesses
the first weakness of the emperor that
we must discuss is his infiltration by
the bini Jesuit Not only was the
emperor's daughter irelan trained by an
Allegiant to the bini Jesuit the
Reverend mother Gaius Helen mohayam was
his personal truth-sayer
to understand why this is a weakness I
have to emphasize just how manipulative
the Benny Jesuit are
many Jesuit don't just manipulate people
they manipulate entire planets they
shape entire cultures craft religions by
hand and guys Helen mohayam was a full
Reverend mother
she possessed ancestral memories going
back countless Generations just on the
power of her voice alone she could make
the emperor dance to whatever tune the
system Hood shows
the fact that shaddam has mohayam in his
ear is a weakness because she will
always serve the will of the bini Jesuit
above all else she will never actually
have the emperor's best interest in mind
unless it aligns with what is best for
the mini Jesuit this was something that
the baron harkonen understood deeply
which was why he never employed of NHS
writ
when you face the emperor you must be
able to say truthfully that you did not
do the deed the witch at the emperor's
elbow will hear your words and know
their truth or falsehood yes I warned
you about that
why haven't you ever bought a Benny
Jesuit Uncle fade rather asked with the
truth Sayer at your side you know my
taste the baron snapped faderatha
studied his uncle said still one would
be valuable for I trust them not the
baron snarled
the next of The Emperor's weaknesses is
his decadence and his sense of comfort
house Carino has been in power for a
very long time this means that they had
acquired a massive amount of wealth
because they were so rich and had been
powerful for so long they essentially
had become complacent the emperor
essentially believed that he was
Untouchable he thought that through his
influence and wealth that he could
basically do whatever he wanted because
of this he likely wasn't fostering good
relationships with the other members of
the lanzarad as house Atreides was the
strength of his sardicar had also begun
to plateau and some even said that the
trades soldiers had surpassed them the
emperor's complacency ties to his next
weakness which is his insecurity and his
jealousy because of the strength and
influence of his house was slipping he
grew insecure he focused that insecurity
on House of Trades because of the fact
that he believed that he could
essentially get away with whatever he
wanted he planned a coup against House
of Charities with how sarconen not
considering the risk of such an
undertaking while the emperor led the
lanzarad he was however not all-powerful
the other great houses also profited
heavily off of chome and got a vote in
things the immensity of wealth involved
here is beyond astronomical
wealth was the thing Chom was the key to
wealth each Noble House dipping from the
company's coffers whatever it could
under the power of directorships those
shown directorships they were the real
evidence of political power in the
Imperium passing with the shifts of
voting strength within the land's red as
it balanced itself against the emperor
and his supporters
the emperor was essentially accountable
to the great houses to some degree at
least for one if the land's rat
discovered the emperor's plot it would
create total chaos among the great
houses no one would feel safe the great
houses of the Imperium would like the
revolt against shaddam secondly the
consequences of this coup if it failed
would be tremendous if he failed and how
to treaties survived the coup it would
be likely that house Atreides themselves
would lead the revolt against him this
would put him in an even worse position
due to the influence and power that
house Atreides already possesses among
the landsrad final weakness of the
emperor that we're going to discuss in
this video was his lack of consideration
for the people of Iraqis specifically
the Freeman the Imperium treats the
Freeman as a nuisance that gets in the
way of spice production he doesn't see
them for what they really are a powerful
group of people with tremendous Wills
who are hardened by the desert just as
the sardicar were hardened by seleusa
secundus this entire time the emperor
could have been utilizing the power of
the Freeman but instead he along with
the harkonans have been trying to
oppress them the Atreides saw the
potential of the Freeman and not only
did the emperor provide the Atreides
with a Chong company directorship when
he gave them the fiefdom of arrakis he
put them into direct contact with one of
the most skilled military forces in the
Galaxy unwittingly take those Freeman
for example
the Renegade people of the desert
by first approximation analysis I can
tell you there are many many more of
them than the Imperium suspects
people live their land
a great many people
to summarize the emperor is a vain
decadent jealous and insecure man he
callously wields the power of his house
without concern for the potential
consequences he overestimates his own
influence and has no actual grasp of the
motives of the binning Jesuit snake that
has coiled itself around him he looks
past a potentially powerful Ally in the
Freeman and inadvertently hands house
Atreides tools that could potentially
help destroy him
alright guys that's it for this video
make sure you like And subscribe for
more Quinn's ideas
also consider donating to keep this
channel afloat by clicking the PayPal
dot me link or checking us out on
patreon thanks guys
thank you
[Music]